hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar making polychromatic
flow cytometry easy after instrument -
characterization and validation I am
Judy Oracle lab routes and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar presented by lab
Rhodes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific thermo Fisher is a world
leader in serving science whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor mind to do so
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I now present
today's speaker Chris hi novice key the
flow cytometry and imaging facility
manager at the qi mr Berghof or Medical
Research Institute in Brisbane Australia
Grace has a strong instrumentation
background and has been managing flow
cytometry core facilities for more than
30 years
she came to qi mr Berghof ER in 1993
having earlier worked as the flow
cytometry facility manager at the Peter
McCallum Cancer Institute in Melbourne
she graduated from RMIT University with
master's and applied science grace is
active with the Australasian cytometry
society organizing courses and meetings
and serves on the executive committee
she has served two terms as councillor
for the active international society for
advancement of cytometry and continues
to be active with the Society Grace's
complete bio is found on the lab roots
website grace high Natsuki will now
begin her presentation
thank you very much Judy and thank you
for your cameras and the opportunity to
share the work we've done here at Qi
marburg offer with cap for instrument
characterization and validations
so my role at Kumar Merkava is to try
and help facilitate good cytometry to
all our internal academic users our
external academic users and also help
some of our commercial clients and
contract work as well as some of the
clinical trial work we do we have users
who have got a reasonably deep
understanding of flow cytometry but then
we also have those who become a little
bit overwhelmed by the complexity of
some of the instrumentation we have
users who prepare a panel on and
analyzer then want to do some sorting
using the same panel and cannot
understand why their populations may
look slightly different and why one
instrument gives them better separation
than others so we embarked on this sort
of experiments to see if we can ask some
of those questions
and so what did we do beads are the
standard used for flow cytometry
performance checking we know that these
beads use different dyes - the ones that
are commonly used when performing flow
cytometry applications and essays as
such we wanted to test our instrument
response to the same fluid comb that we
use for our day-to-day essays and not
just the dyes that are attached to the
beads another point is that the
brightness or staining index that's
provided by vendors give us an
indication of how bright some of these
fluorochromes may be but that is not
always the same on our instruments on my
instrument or your instrument so we saw
61 and 660 134 antibodies with 46th
floor Chrome's and a number of different
clones I would have been ideal to have
had the same clone for all the different
fluorochromes but we weren't able to
obtain all 46 in the same clone and
initially we started using normal
healthy volunteer peripheral blood but
as you can imagine and we needed a lot
of blood from one volunteer and so we
could avoid any very variability from
different multiple donors in one
experiment after a while we decided to
start using comm peds as well and the
reason is that campaigns don't change
from day to day or individual to
individuals the concentration is always
constant and it's a lot easier to use
comp beads and large volumes of blood
from different volunteers
so polychromatic flow cytometry has
grown rapidly over the last five to ten
years you know many years ago we had the
organic dyes like sexy and some of the
photos proteins like PE and APC then
flung came some of the tandem dyes two
dots and more recently than you sewage
and dives this has increased the
availability of new dyes along with new
instrumentation that's able to require
many more parameters simultaneously and
allowing us to measure so many more
antigens simultaneously on one single
cell having a good handle on instrument
characteristics the optical
configuration can have a big impact on
the ability to resolve many different
some sub cell populations
many vendors that do sell reagents with
the different floral frames will give us
an indication of their level of
brightness and some vendors will rank
these dyes as completely in this table
but this ranking may be different on
your instrument or my instrument either
because of my optical configuration is
different or I you know or I can use
different collection optics my laser
excitation power or wavelength may be
different as well
you know here we have some fluid combs
that are ranked in order of brightness
but also grouped in either high
brightness medium or low
and here again we've got the rate from
very low to very high to very low also
numerically from a five out to a one low
so here is the list of the Florrick
roads that we used in our instrument
characterization as well as the CD float
CD for clone that was associated with
that Florrick Rome
there were three main vendors that we
obtained our antibodies from and I'll
name them a B and C the cd4 clone sk3
was the most common one used followed by
the RPO t4 and then a couple of the X
3.5 clones and you can also see that
with some of the antibodies the same
clone with that where the same
chloroquine was available from a number
of different for from all the vendors
for a PC we could get for a number of
the vendors
so this table shows us the optical
configuration of the instruments at our
Institute which were used for these in
some experiments and which we obtained
our individual instrument
characteristics on you can see that some
of the instruments have got identical
optical configurations such as the four
tests of one and two are identical the
for test of four and five are also
identical so they have the same lasers
the same dichroic the same collection
filters and whereas the other ones may
have slight variations with some of
their band pass filters and also psycho
X I haven't listed their dichroic
filters or the searing optics here that
they may also differ slightly from
instrument to instrument
okay sir everybody tisha for antibodies
treated for both the normal healthy
volunteer or the peripheral blood but we
also did teachers competitors using the
top beats we expressed the the Teeter as
protein in my programs for mill we
wanted to make sure that the same amount
of antibody is present from all the
antibiotics that we tested and the only
difference was the the flora Chrome that
we were using and we wanted to also make
sure that I mean once you have a teeter
with your peripheral blood that's a lot
easier to obtain but with can't beat we
really wanted to make sure that the
amount of protein because of all the
binding sites on on competes we wanted
to make sure that the protein between
all the fluorochromes was is the same
for the beads
so the staining index what is sustaining
a noose and what does the staining index
tell us it lets us know how result how
well resolved a population is from the
background or from the the negative
population the brighter the signal above
the background or the unstained in the
sample
the higher the staining index
you
Oh
for all the data required for each
antibody from each tailor we calculated
the staining index you calculate the
mean fluorescence intensity or the MFI
of the positive cell population the MFI
of the negative cell population and
calculate the staining the standard
deviation of the negative population and
then you use the formula where you
subtract the negative MFI from the
positive MFI and divide it by 2 times
the standard deviation of the negative
population as the negative population
expands or the sustaining index cm so
the standard deviation will also
increase which will then have an effect
on the the staining index
the sailing index allows us to determine
how well resolved our city fall
population is from the background or the
negative populations
here's an example of some of the
staining index results we've got and
what we considered was the optimal
t-shirt so we said this for all the the
floor recruits I've also plotted the
positive medium fluorescence and the
negative medium fluorescence and then in
red we can see the staining index you
can also see that sometimes over if a
population if you've got the highest
mean fluorescence intensity on a
positive population that doesn't
necessarily mean that that higher
teacher or or that concentration is
going to give you the best staining
index so sometimes you will get an
increase in the in the negative which
will have an effect on the total
staining index or that final staining
index number so it's about getting the
best separation between your negative
cells and and your positive cells
so we've been plotted all our different
staining indexes for the different
antibody teachers and what we can see on
this plot is what we were looking for
we've got three different vendors with
the same PE cd4 clone the results are
very very similar on each instrument and
these two instruments are identical same
lasers same optical configuration but
the staining index is markedly different
on on both of them and this is what we
hope to achieve by performing these
experiments and seeing which instrument
behaves differently or how they behave
differently with the different filler
chrome
we also did some volt raishin
experiments where we altered the the the
voltage for each detector just to see
what was the best voltage for you know
the the different fluorochromes and
looked at the range where you do get a
better you know signal between your
negative and the positive cells
so the results and here we've got one of
our response from one of our instruments
one of our vortecies
it has five lasers and we're able to
configure the instrument to acquire data
from all the pleura Chrome's we test it
so we can see here that the two
fluorochromes that give us the best best
staining index are from two different
vendors they're excited by the same
laser selected from the same detector
and also these two fluke runs have got
similar sectoral properties so what this
is indicating is that the detectives
that are picking up those fluorochromes
are very sensitive to that and the
spectrum and also at those two fluid
Chrome's are reasonably bright as well
go back
so here we've got the four instruments
there are two instruments up the two top
instruments are identical in their
optical configuration and the bottom two
are also identical with their optical
configurations the two on the left are
older instruments the f h o4 and the F
for a our older instruments and the two
on the right
have been purchased in the you know
more recently we the the two on the left
were very popular they're all used you
know they usually quite booked out and
users liked the configuration they like
to run their expense and they said well
we need instruments that are exactly the
same so we purchased additional
instruments with the same configuration
to keep our users happy and we can see
that the older instruments don't have as
little responses than you or ones and
later on in this presentation I will try
to dress why this is or why I think you
know this is
um here we have one of our selfs orders
and you can see that the response to
most of the fluorochromes is very good
that's a response to the fluorochromes
excited by the 561 slaver are very good
just before we perform these instruments
performing characteristics see we had a
few issues with the instrument and the
561 laser died so we've got a brand new
laser all the fibers everything had been
replaced and everything has been
realigned which would be another reason
why the the yellow green is giving us
much superior signals to to the rest of
the fluorochromes so this is the
streaming air cell sorter itself our mo
flow and again we've got an excellent
response to the yellow-green
fluorochromes one thing that we did do
for this instrument when the the new
yellow the new threat of protein dyes
became popular we purchased a reasonably
high powered laser to excite some of
these fluorescent proteins such as in
cherry so the power on from this laser
is a lot lot higher than the the other
the power on the other lasers on onions
also can explain why we're getting such
a good response
so do the same fluorochromes have better
a response on our instruments from the
bin different vendors snow not really
they're all pretty much the same
we compared the same city for clone with
the same flora quote from different
vendors and found that they pretty much
gave similar results on all our
different instruments so we've got the
APC fit CP so 7 MPA and all the
instruments
and the responses so they all work where
they you know where you've got a better
response from one slur at crome you also
got a reasonably good response from the
the other vendors as well
comparisons between different
fluorochromes but where you're using the
same to take that so when you compare
different pros from different vendors
there are differences and this could be
due to the actual brightness of the dye
but it could also be due to the specific
collection optics of their instruments
you know some filters may be better
suited for a particular fluid chrome
than another and we can't you know
constantly be changing our collection
filters will come a date from one floor
chrome you know for one experiment to
another and you can see that you know
some of the the emission spectra are
reasonably close but they're not all
identical
so in an ideal flow cytometry will you
know a days would have met a very narrow
spectral band with snow or very little
spillover signal into different
detectors reality is fluorochromes admit
you know into a whole lot of other
detectives where you don't want them to
either two adjacent detectives but also
to other detectives where you've got
different excitation wavelength and
sometimes this spillover can be quite
significant and this will make
multicolored or polychromatic photometer
panel design difficult when there's
spillover of this fluorescence into
multiple detectors it will have an
effect by spraying the nominal negative
cell distribution and this can have a
huge impact on the ability to resolve
some populations especially those that
have got a very low antigen expression
so what we did from after we obtained
all these instruments characteristics we
used a featuring flo-jo that is able to
calculate the silho the spreading matrix
between the different floral chrome
combination the software does make it
easy to recognize which floral chrome
combination should best be avoided as
they do have a very very high level of
silvering to each other so if it cannot
avoid using some of these combinations
you should try and assign the the dim
receptors to the bright skies that do
have a minimal you know spillover and in
the table you can see some examples
where you've thought you know our PE
size 5 and a B be 700
this you know that value is quite high
and you know if you had to deem
populations on either of those low
claims you may not be able to resolve
that population very well
so
have another table where we're able to
summarize all that the spillover and you
can see you know which fluorochromes
are going to give you quite high
you know still over of of that fluid
chrome into the other detectors
[Music]
and you can you can actually calculate
the total thread from that each dye
contributes and it kind of lets you know
whether that diet is going to you know
work well or play well with you know
some of the other dyes which is very
useful when you're designing a new panel
and also when you're adding you know one
or two extra blue chromis or markers to
already prepared panel
so down the bottom here you can also
calculate the total spread and
detectives that have got very low values
will be most sensitive for detecting
when you've got you know all the other
colors used and this is very important
when you're trying to resolve very low
and in populations and again you know
those dim markers try and put them on
the brightest day with the lease fred's
to try and you know I have an absolute
guarantee success
so I'm going to try and explain what I
what I think some of the reasons are for
the differences in staining index so
some of the things that may have an
effect on on the staining index and how
well we're able to resolve our selves of
interest is the laser power on one of
our analyzers were able to change the
laser power and we ran some eight peak
rainbow beads just to see the effect of
the laser power and the ability to
resolve all eight Peaks as we increase
the laser power we're able to resolve
from the dimmer feed populations we can
see that when you're here we've
collected two different
[Music]
we've used two different collection
filters for these beads and you can see
that no matter how high you turn up the
laser some of the dim populations are
not as well resolved in the the higher
wavelength to 670 - 30 collection and
that's because the dye emission doesn't
peak around that area it sort of picks
at the lower wavelength
so here we also looked at another
analyzer where we're again also able to
change the laser power and the effect it
did have on resolving 8pp
so laser power is important maybe not so
when you some of the the bright
expressing beams or bright expressing
dyes but where you do have very or very
low antigens or very dim populations
laser power can help improve the
resolution
and again
this is another representation of how
the laser power does have an effect on
resolving the low bee populations
so optics of optical filters and pass
filters dichroic filters they've made of
different layers and coatings that allow
you to collect the different wavelengths
of interest our li ER in the
presentation I showed a couple of
instruments which in theory should have
been identical having the same optical
layout but we saw that with some of
these we knew that some of the newer
instruments gave a subset of staining
index than the older ones and one reason
for this is that the bandpass filters in
the older instruments have degraded so
environmental deterioration due to
either moisture getting into some of the
the layers on the bandpass filters will
have a big impact on how well these
filters behave and brisbin's
in Australia in the subtropics and our
summers are hot and very very humid and
no matter how hard we try and control
the humidity and keep you know the the
temperatures at a constant level there
is still keep a lot of moisture in the
air and I'm pretty sure that a lot of
the our bandpass filters do degrade just
because you know there is a lot of
moisture in the air and something that
you can try out there is if you take
your filters out of your instrument if
you don't think they're you know
performing well and just put them up
against some light you can actually
start to see some degradation and when
when you do start to see that you know
it's time to to swap the filters there
are different vendors that do supply
filters that you know as the quality of
the filter goes up you know so does the
surprise
so in this slide we can see you know the
different effects of all the effects
that that filters can have on how well
we're able to resolve populations you
know we hear we've run some eight peak
rainbow beads and what only the bandpass
filter collecting the signal everything
else was the same the Dyke ropes the
laser power and we use the same bandpass
filter of collecting five thirty thirty
wavelengths some of the new filters may
not be as good as you know one would
think some of the older ones you can see
are so bad that you can't even resolve
you know some of the higher peak takes
well so you know band power filters do
play a big big part in how well you're
able to or how bright a signal you're
getting on on your instrument
so you know if your instruments are
quite a few years old it's really worth
sitting down and and checking you know
have your filters degraded do they need
to be replaced and if so when you do a
place and you'll find that there's a
marked difference on how well your
instrument will start to perform
so photo photo detectors or
photomultiplier tubes converts a photon
of light being emitted from our floor
prints and convert these into an
electronic signal that we can then
measure and display in flow cytometry as
the number of photons hitting the
detector increases the current that the
resulting current also increases motor
multiply tubes have got different
responses to different wavelengths and
you know the manufacturers will select
photo multiply choose for a range of
wavelengths to be able to detect within
the visible range
of
some photomultiplier tubes have got you
know much better responses to a
particular wavelength than others and
sometimes you know they may not be
placed in you know the the best the most
ideal spot for a very you know authoress
most suitable wavelength years ago i
with the instruments i had i used to
remove all the photomultiplier tubes
from an instrument and then you know
test each one individually for different
wavelength responses and i would then
place them on my machine in positions
that were best suited to collect that
particular wavelength the newer
instruments these days make that a
little bit more difficult everything
sort of you know bolted down and locked
in the instruments some of the the cell
thought is still allow you to do that
but most of the analyzers it's not so
easy to do anymore and something else
that people should be aware of if you do
have very very bright dyes that where
you've got a very high signal going to
that detector in there at that higher
detection rate some of the the
photomultiplier tubes may not respond in
a linear fashion anymore and they do
start to waver when you know that the
incident light is very very high
you
there's a queue what is your queue so
the Q value gives you an indication of
how efficiently detector is able to
convert that flight signal well that's
the essence signal to an electronic
signal or photoelectrons they're going
to sell that perhaps has 10 fluorescent
molecules being emitted hit the detector
and the conversion is 5 photoelectrons
then you know the Q value would be we've
got a 50/50 percent conversion the
average conversion in most flow
cytometer which is very good is around
maybe 20 to 30 percent so not every
single fluorescent molecule gets
converted into a photoelectron
so what kind of things affect the
q-value as I showed earlier laser power
but also laser alignment you may have a
laser with really good power but if it's
not aligned properly and it's not
focused properly you're not going to get
the most optimal signal when weenus you
know you really need to make sure that
you look after your instruments you know
you've got to have a clean flow cell or
nozzle make sure your you know all your
steering or your objectives are clean
the lenses are clean you know if you've
got neutral density filters in front of
some of your detectors that will also
decrease the the Q value you know as I
said before P and T sensitivity you know
some detectives
you know it better to give a better
response to some wavelengths and some
are less sensitive in especially in some
of the red wavelengths and also how well
does that PMT respond to different
wavelengths
so ranking died brightness and flora
chrome response on individual flow
cytometry
you know they are different you know the
panties has got different responses to
different wavelengths you know your
summer to model how you know it what its
optical configuration is and how much
noise do you actually having your
detector will play a part as well you
know do you have good clean powers or
well you know is your lab reasonably
noisy all these things will have a part
we know that some dyes are brighter than
others but because of the variation in
instrument to instrument the collection
optics you will get a different response
and also something that is important is
how well you look after your instrument
and you know how how clean the the
optics are and you know if things do
start to degrade we really it really is
a good idea to want to replace some of
your bad power filters
so what can we do to improve how we
select different markers associated with
slower crimes when designing our panel
ranking fluorochromes for Angel in JH
instruments you know what which which is
what we've done is a good start
and what we've done here on one of our
four testers is that we've grouped you
know the different little combs into you
know very high you know high moderate
low to very low and the actual that
these groups of high or low blue chrome
you know brightness are going to be
different for each instrument so what
you know the the flow crimes that are
going to be very high on one instrument
may not be the same on another
instrument
so people need to be aware of that if
they're going to be staying a certain
panel using you know that they've
designed on one of the instruments they
may not get as good a result on some of
the other instruments
things to consider when you are going to
be designing you know multicolor panel
you know you really need to determine
you know define how your dye
brightnesses on an instrument and try
and avoid any fluorochromes that do
Bulova you don't you know the less
overlap to read you know the better your
resolution
another suggestion is you know if some
of the dyes are overlapping then try and
use markers all those are overlapping
fluorochromes that don't express you
know something like you know T and B
cells and try and choose bright bright
dyes for some of the low expression
markers especially the fluid creams that
don't have a lot of fill over understand
the biology of your antigen or you know
what you try to what the question is
you're asking with your experiments
define you know the dye brightness for
each analyzer and then also consider the
the spreading error of that dye on the
under and on the instrument that you're
going to be using also something you
need to take into consideration is you
know some of the markers you're looking
at transient you know due to something
biological have to happen for that
marker to be expressed and in those
cases you know really try and use
fluorochromes
that are bright or have very minimal
spillover no your flow cytometry
so what do we need to do well we
continually update and educate our
facility users about dye complexity and
panel design you know we emphasize the
individual optical characteristics
within the facility and we'll sit down
with our users and help tailor their
panel you know to the instrument of
their choice or we we've ranked or
layered I and use you know use some of
the features in software that will allow
you to calculate the the spread of your
fluorochromes
or that particular photometer and you
know provide this is a really good
resource that facility uses you know to
help guide them better panel design and
you know some of the more complex home
and that we've been doing for the
clinical trials that we do here you know
we're going to do the best advice and
service for our service facility to our
users and we will modify our increments
as as new dyes come on the market - and
helps you know further improve the
service to our users
and I just wanted to thank the rest of
the gang here and it was a pretty major
you know day or days multiple days when
we do this work you know every single
person had an instrument and they
basically almost spent the whole day on
on each instrument running all the
different healers and all the different
fluorochromes just to get all this
started together you get it by everyone
and thank you so in any questions
Thank You grace for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button grace hi Gossett II will
answer as many questions as time permits
the first question is how important is
my tration of each antibody conjugate
used
it's very important there's as we saw
with the the straining index you know
having the highest Teeter doesn't always
give you the best separation of the
cells of interest you may actually start
to increase the background a little bit
more if you do have too high
concentration and then again if you
don't have enough if your concentration
of your antibody is too low you know
you're not going to get a very good
signal either so it is it's crucial that
you do cater your antibody you know
before you start doing any experiments
thank you you mentioned doing an
antibody titer using comp beads how does
this compare to titration on the cells
and what are the advantages and
disadvantages of doing titration using
coffee
so their advantages are that you don't
need to collect you know large volumes
of blood for all the fluorochromes you
can imagine you know 61 different
antibodies with you know numerous taters
and we wanted to to make sure we had you
know there's this the same sample so you
do need to collect a lot of blood which
you know you know some volunteers are
happy to give it you know after a while
but with comp beats they're they're
they're you know if you get the same lot
number they're constant the
concentration is the same and the only
disadvantage with using kompy's you they
do have a lot more receptors on the
surface so you know the amount of
antibodies that will bind to them is
always a lot higher so you will end up
using a lot more antibodies so what we
did do we really try to make sure that
the concentration that we used was
constant for every compete so there you
know there's pluses and minuses for both
but comp aids you know they're all the
time and you know there isn't as much
effort in preparing them as what you
need to put in when you are using you
know truthful blood thank you your next
one is I like how you classified died
into brightness categories Saint Jim mod
moderate I guess bright very bright what
about doing this for antigen density
information say low medium high density
yes that that is important as well so
we're you know if you do have a high
high-end to Jin density you know you
would rank that you know we're you know
what you expect or whether you are going
to get a high
antigen density and you would you could
you would use the cells or you reduce
the fluorochromes that maybe aren't as
bright with some of the antigens that
are bright so for example something like
cd8 you know has got a very high antigen
density you could use some of the the
dimmer dyes on something like cd8
whereas you know other markers or that
may have a very low antigen density you
would assign some of the brighter dye
and you would also try and use the dyes
that are bright but also ones that don't
give you too much of a overfill over
and then the the antigens that you're
not sure of or that you're testing for
and you don't know what their expression
is going to be or ones where there is a
transient expression and you which again
you'll try and assign guys to those that
you know don't have too much other
spillover and are reasonably bright as
well
thank you okay if the nephilim is can
you summarize the instrument
characterization studies you recommend
doing for any flow cytometry does this
characterization ever need to be
repeated so it's it should be repeated
every time you know if you if you have
your photo multiplier tubes changed or
you know the instruments realigned you
know you get a new laser you you know
any of the optical components are are
changed it will make a big difference
one of the older instruments that did
give us poor responses we've you know
started to purchase new filters and we
haven't repeated the studies that will
you know once we start doing this again
we'll be able to see a marked difference
and just show you know the difference
between you know what the
characteristics were before we were
placed a lot of the filters and then you
know what sensed of how the instrument
behaves after some of the optical
components were a change so you know
really realistically it will yes the
characteristics will change as soon as
you you know change anything on the
instrument and also over time you know
as I showed you some of the slides you
know things will degrade and you know
that the characteristics won't be as
good as you know what they may have been
you know a few years prior
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question that will be this one
what do you think is the main reason for
the differences in the staining index on
different instruments for the same dye
so the main the main difference could be
the the valet so depending on you know
some of the yellow-green dyes if you're
exciting them with the yellow green
laser you are going to get a better
response some instruments don't have a
yellow green laser they're using you
know a 488 excitation which isn't as
optimal for those dyes so you're not
actually exciting the diet it's optimal
absorption and the other component which
i think is very important over the
actual collection filters I found that
they make a huge difference as to how
good a you know a signal you get you
know depending on on the quality of the
filter and you know whether it has
degraded and also to some effect the the
actual photomultiplier tube some you
know just have a little bit better then
sative 'ti you know to certain spectral
yeah wavelengths
well I would like to once again thank
grace I Nobbs be for her presentation
grace do you have any final comments
[Music]
no but if any I can't think of any at
the moment but if anybody you know would
like to ask any questions please feel
free to contact me my contact details
are on our website there joy Marburger
website well thank you and I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
as grace said questions we did not have
time for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through January
2019 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye